y podemos detectar cinco sabores cada
sabor depende de un receptor en
particular que se encuentra en alguna
parte de la lengua las cinco cosas que
podemos saborear son compuestos amargos
compuestos salados
compuestos dulces compuestos ácidos y
uno más que se llama unam y este es
básicamente la habilidad de percibir o
saborear una molécula particular llamada
glutamato estos cinco sabores dependen
de un receptor en particular vamos a
imaginar que aquí hay una lengua esta es
la parte de adelante y esta es la parte
de atrás y básicamente tenemos papilas
gustativas en toda la lengua estás
papilas están por todas partes de la
lengua aunque están mayormente ubicadas
en la parte anterior o adelante de la
lengua es decir que hay más cantidad de
papilas en esta parte anterior de la
lengua en comparación con la parte de
atrás o posterior existen tres tipos
diferentes de papilas gustativas una se
ven más o menos así y se llaman
fungiformes vamos a escribirlo y esto
se encuentra aquí en la parte anterior
de la lengua
también existen papilas que se ven así
donde los pequeños botones gustativos
están aquí y se conocen como papilas
foliadas y éstas se encuentran
principalmente a los lados de la lengua
finalmente hay papilas que tienen esta
forma y cuyos botones gustativos se
encuentran a los lados estas se llaman
papilas calcifer mes y se encuentran en
la parte posterior de la lengua aquí
atrás y si viéramos de cerca a uno de
los botones gustativos que hay en las
papilas veríamos un pequeño poro y en
este polo encontraríamos muchos tipos de
células aquí dibujo una célula aquí
dibujo otro tipo de célula aquí un
tercer tipo de célula y así
sucesivamente básicamente cada una de
estas células es responsable de percibir
cada uno de estos sabores
por ejemplo imaginemos que esta célula
de color rosado de aquí es la
responsable de detectar sabores salados
y que esta célula blanca es responsable
de detectar sabores dulces
sucesivamente la idea general es que
cada una de estas células en este botón
gustativo esto es un botón y cada botón
contiene todas las diferentes células
que detectan sabores por lo que cada uno
de los botones puede detectar compuestos
amargos salados dulces
ácidos y umami y estos botones que
agrupados forman papilas se encuentran
por toda la lengua aunque en mayor
cantidad en la parte anterior de la
lengua otra forma de decir esto es que
podemos detectar todos estos cinco
sabores en toda la lengua por lo que no
es que sólo podamos detectar los
compuestos amargos en esta parte de la
lengua y los compuestos salados sólo
puedan detectarse en esta otra región y
los compuestos dulces solamente en esta
parte este no es el caso no sucede así
lo que sucede es que podemos detectar
estos cinco compuestos en toda la lengua
aunque la mayoría de las papilas se
encuentran en la parte anterior de la
lengua a continuación voy a hablar del
modelo de líneas marcadas
aquí tenemos un botón gustativo y como
mencioné antes aquí están todos los
diferentes tipos de células y cada una
de estas células se especializa en uno
de los diferentes sabores lo que podemos
ver aquí abajo es que cada célula tiene
un pequeño acción que sale de ella aquí
lo interesante es que estos acciones se
mantienen separados durante todo el
camino hacia el cerebro todas éstas se
proyectan hasta que alcanzan el cerebro
y hacen sinapsis en diferentes partes de
él imaginemos que esto es la corteza
gustativa es decir que es la parte del
cerebro que recibe la información que
viene de las diferentes células
gustativas cada uno de estos diferentes
acciones hacen sinapsis en diferentes
partes del cerebro por ejemplo este
acción asesina pis por aquí y cada uno
de los axones de cada célula gustativa
que es de color azul digamos que esta
célula detecta lo dulce cada una de las
células que detectan lo dulce proyecta
sus acciones a la misma región de la
corteza gustativa por lo que podemos
decir que esta es la región dulce
esa gustativa de forma similar todas las
células de color verde que podemos
imaginar son las células que detectan el
sabor amargo
las células verdes detectan el sabor
amargo todas harán sinapsis en una parte
de la corteza gustativa esta es la parte
amarga de la corteza gustativa está muy
enojada con el mundo así es básicamente
la forma en que las células gustativas
envían información al cerebro de hecho
la envían a través de acciones dedicados
y nunca se mezclan este es el modelo de
líneas marcadas vamos a escribirlo
modelo de líneas marcadas y lo que dice
este modelo es que cada una de estas
células tiene su línea marcada dedicada
y esta distinción se lleva durante todo
el camino hasta la corteza misma ahora
veamos de forma individual una célula
gustativa dibujemos una célula
individual
aquí está su acción
estos pelitos son proyecciones hacia la
lengua y este es el núcleo de la célula
aquí lo que sucede es que digamos que
esta es una célula dulce imaginemos que
por aquí hay una molécula de glucosa
porque estamos comiendo pastel así que
esta molécula de glucosa llega a la
lengua y a esta célula dulce porque esta
célula es dulce es dulce porque tiene
receptores en la membrana que son
sensibles a la glucosa y otras moléculas
dulces cuando la glucosa se enlaza a
esta célula dispara una serie de eventos
que finalmente permite a la célula
despolarizar se dispara un potencial de
acción a través del axón hacia el
cerebro
ya mencionamos que hay cinco tipos de
sabores diferentes dulce y mami amargo
ácido y salado las células gustativas de
los tres primeros sabores tienen
receptores similares y estos receptores
se llaman receptores acoplados a
proteínas g y voy a dibujarlo esta es la
proteína e imaginemos que esta es la
membrana celular esta proteína es un
receptor y el receptor se enlaza con un
ligando o molécula señalizadora
imaginemos que tenemos glucosa en este
caso una molécula de glucosa el ligando
llega y se une al receptor
el receptor pasa por un cambio de
conformación que básicamente ocasiona
que la proteína g con la que está
acoplada y que estoy indicando acá se
disocie del receptor por lo que este
enlace se rompe y se suelta la proteína
g
la proteína g puede hacer varias cosas
dentro de la célula esta parte es dentro
de la célula y esta otra parte es afuera
de la célula así que la proteína que
puede hacer varias cosas una de
cosas que puede hacer la proteína g
cuando se disocia del receptor es que
puede abrir algunos canales iónicos así
que la proteína g se libera y abre
canales iónicos la apertura de los
canales iónicos mediante el cambio de
conformación puede hacer que las células
se des polaris y dispare un potencial de
acción por otra parte las células
gustativas de estos dos sabores ácido y
salado usan los canales iónicos en lugar
de usar un receptor con proteína g estos
utilizan solamente un receptor
imaginemos que este es el receptor que
estoy dibujando aquí en el caso del
sabor salado imaginemos que por aquí hay
una molécula de cloruro de sodio que
llega al receptor y se enlaza con este
receptor iónico y hace que este receptor
se abra el receptor se abre y permite
que un ión positivo que se encuentra
fuera de la célula entre a ella cuando
los iones positivos entran a la célula
hacen que la célula se despoliticen y
dispare un potencial de acción y ese
potencial de acción llegará al ser
veamos qué ocurriría si pusiéramos un
receptor de sal dentro de una célula
dulce aquí dibujo una célula dulce y la
razón por la que esta célula es dulce es
porque va a tener receptores en su
membrana que se enlazan con la glucosa
imaginemos que tomamos un receptor de
sal que como dije previamente los
receptores de sal son canales iónicos si
recuerdan el modelo de líneas marcadas
básicamente dice que una célula
particular en este caso una célula dulce
tiene una acción que va a llegar al
cerebro y el cerebro debido a que este
acción pertenece a una célula dulce va a
detectar el compuesto que está asociado
con esta célula dulce pues como dulce y
lo que ocurre cuando ponemos un receptor
de sal en una célula dulce es que cuando
llega esta molécula de cloruro de sodio
o de sal y dispara este receptor al
dispararse este receptor va a abrirse y
va a permitir que los iones positivos
que están flotando afuera entren a la
célula de manera que esta célula dulce
se des polariza y
un potencial de acción y para el momento
en el que este potencial de acción llega
al cerebro el cerebro no puede
diferenciar entre una molécula de dulce
y una molécula de sal por lo que tanto
el azúcar como la sal van a disparar
esta célula dulce pero como el cerebro
ha establecido que esta es una célula
dulce y cada vez que estas células se
disparan normalmente es por algo dulce
el cerebro va a pensar que este
compuesto salado en realidad es un
compuesto dulce lo va a detectar como
algo dulce así que si pusiéramos un
receptor de sal dentro de una célula
dulce engañaríamos al cerebro para que
piense que algo salado como el cloruro
de sodio es algo dulce